so yesterday I told you we would talk
about this today and now I want to there
are starting to be numerous reports
where the headline is the Russia Ukraine
war the invasion of Ukraine by Russia
could last 10 to 20 years
and I think it's important to understand
that it wouldn't be 10 to 20 years like
the last six days but it's still
important to understand sort of what's
at stake here
there's an interesting article in the
week called the U.S and Britain
reportedly believe Ukraine war could
last 10 to 20 years and become a Russian
Quagmire and if you look at the details
it says despite moscow's shambolic start
to its campaign most western officials
and analysts believe Russia will turn to
criminal Siege tactics and eventually
find a way to break through Ukraine's
Fierce and Valiant resistance
um a U.S official tells CBS News Russia
could tactically seize kievan Ukraine in
four to six weeks so in terms of like
now
four to six weeks is being mentioned but
as this goes on the UK foreign secretary
estimated it would be a 10-year War
makers at the Capitol were told Monday
it is likely to last 10 15 or 20 years
and that ultimately Russia will lose now
of course when you're thinking about
those time frames we are talking about
protracted sort of
separatist type conflicts in Border
areas not 10 to 20 years of nightly
bombing of Kiev but that doesn't mean
that it's not going to be absolutely
horrifying here's a little bit of a
discussion about this from earlier this
week but this is only gonna get uglier
for the president of the United States
and for the people of Ukraine members of
Congress briefed that this this war
could go on 10 20 years this could end
up being an albatross for the President
Biden and his presidency dealing with
this it absolutely could be and this we
are watching live broadcast on
television a human rights catastrophe so
for the president who has said he's
putting human rights back at the center
of the agenda he's also drawn a very
bright line to say we won't use military
force to defend it we will if you go a
little bit farther west and touch our
NATO allies but the criticism has been
such a bright line can actually
encourage Vladimir Putin to know the
limit so that is a question that is
increasingly coming up which as well as
is Joe Biden potentially going to have
to go back on that but the main thing I
want to focus on and I don't I don't
believe that he will on troops on the
ground I think he's not going to do it
um there's a separate economic question
here which is can the Russian economy
support a conflict for 10 or 20 years
and the answer is what many economic
analysts are saying and of course
economic economic analyst predictions
are worth what most of us pay for them
which is nothing but the idea that the
damage economically that Russia will
take if there are four to six more weeks
of this
itself may take 10 to 20 years to
recover from
and when you think about well if that's
the case and where will Putin be in 10
or 20 years time we don't even know if
he's sick now as increasingly as being
discussed if it's going to be bad
regardless it's not a disincentive to
just continue fighting for Russia now I
think the more likely scenario
is this does not last as a war for 10
years but it's the four to six weeks
that's being discussed but the economic
repercussions do extend to a decade and
Beyond a decade who can predict but
certainly you know that that is
plausible
um look at Venezuela right I mean you
know they're not fighting a war
but they've had a disastrous economic
collapse and they survive but there's a
question as to what what can a society
sustain for these periods of time and
isolated countries survive it's a matter
of how much do the people suffer how
much are the Russian people willing or
able to put up with and if you go back
to the collapse of the Soviet Union
that was one of the most rapid
declines in standard of living and
quality of life that countries have
faced and what's happening in Russia
I don't want to say it would be
equivalent but
it would be probably the the biggest
similar decline or even close to in
scope and size and you know you look at
the collapse of the USSR and you're
talking about decreased life expectancy
and and all of these other things so
when we say 10 to 20 years I mean listen
like every other prediction
take it with a grain of salt but
understand it could be bad for 10 to 20
years in Russia economically it's not
going to be 10 to 20 years of what we've
all been watching on TV for six days
that is not possible but many other
things could last that long really
interesting story a Kremlin policy
advisor is revealing that he sees the
invasion of Ukraine as shocking and
embarrassing to Russia this is Andre
cortunov who's been previously known for
defending the actions of Russia and he
says he doesn't this is me paraphrasing
he doesn't know what the hell Putin is
thinking with what he is doing now let's
look at some actual clips of this
um take a look I am trying to keep
going I'm trying to continue doing what
I'm doing but of course I'm depressed
you know all of us are depressed and I
think that
it's it's very embarrassing
for all of us not only because we turned
out to be wrong but uh also because of
course you know
Russia and all Russians will be in a
difficult position
uh in uh in many countries
not even only Western countries but all
over the place for a long time yeah so I
mean listen he's not quote turning on
Putin necessarily in the most overt way
um but this is uh this is a pretty big
step back for someone who's typically a
Kremlin uh apologist let's look at um oh
no that's the that was the only clip I
had so I think the the important
takeaway here yesterday we had the story
about anecdotally
some Russian troops just surrendering
the stalled Convoy not enough gas for
tanks soldiers crying and taking food
for and accepting not taking accepting
food and drinks from ukrainians and
calling their mom and saying I don't
know what the hell I'm doing here quite
frankly we're seeing that
we're seeing Putin increasingly isolated
both figuratively and literally sitting
at the end of a 50-foot table from
advisors that maybe he fears might turn
on him and try to kill him still no
clear explanation why the table is so
long and why he's sitting so far and in
the middle you have everything you still
have a Russian military that's so
overwhelmingly bigger than the Ukrainian
forces that they have the ability
they'll take losses but they have the
ability to continue for a serious period
of time what will things look like by
Monday I don't know I don't want to
spend a ton of time on this but so many
of you emailed me about it that I do
want to say a little bit about it um yet
two days ago uh the Florida Republican
Governor Ron DeSantis uh appeared with
some high schoolers
and behaved in a just disgusting manner
he went over to them and he told them
almost like in a bullying way
take the masks off check this out
you do not have to wear those masks I
mean please
honestly it's not doing anything and we
got to stop with this code is theater so
if you want to wear it fine but this is
a this is ridiculous
foreign
well it's good to be at USF
[Laughter]
now um so I mean like listen first of
all what a leader right we're not
against masks we just don't think the
government should be telling you to wear
them but I'm going to tell you not to
wear them and I'm here from the
government come on dude and uh when you
look at this guy I understand why 28 of
CPAC wants this guy to be the Republican
nominee because he's sort of like a more
aggressive more competent more dangerous
version of trump this guy is Trump but
slightly less nuts in in the way of
being cartoonish but very very dangerous
now one kid decided to keep the mask on
and some people are saying oh wow what a
hero whatever what's Wild is this is not
even the craziest part of desantis's
very very strange appearance at uh in in
Florida at this Workforce education
event he also bizarrely attacked France
kind of playing up this story that
France is is basically weak and [ __ ]
like we're still doing these stupid
tropes yeah Ron DeSantis is doing them a
lot of other places around the world
they just fold the minute there's any
type of adversity I mean can you imagine
if he went into France would they do
anything to put up a fight probably not
um and so those folks um you know are
stepping up but it's a there's a lot of
problems I think between now and then
and I think unfortunately it's going to
end up very very ugly kick I mean guys
this is a governor whose analysis of the
Russian invasion of Ukraine is the
people in Ukraine are are actually uh uh
doing something they're trying to resist
whereas
[ __ ] French people wouldn't do anything
I mean these are some of the most base
coarse tropes that have been floating
around for 20 years remember John Kerry
back when he ran against uh George W
bush for president in 2004
um the whole idea because Carrie speaks
French the whole thing was oh carries a
[ __ ] because he speaks French these are
such dumb tropes and they still exist
with people like DeSantis and and the
the people that follow DeSantis here's
one last clip and here's DeSantis asked
did you agree with anything Joe Biden
said in his State of the Union and he
kind of hems and Haws uh and gives a
very weird answer
um you know I mean I think
um I I have to think about
um some of the stuff well I mean I agree
you know if you think about what they've
done fauci is in the witness protection
program now they don't want him out they
no they they've never supported any if
you if you listen so I guess what the
scientist is saying it's a very
backhanded compliment he seems to be
saying
the aspect of the State of the Union
Address that I agreed agreed with
is that Biden didn't mention fauci
and fauci wasn't there I guess I mean
it's a it's a really backhanded
compliment it's really not a compliment
listen to them they never supported all
these policies that were so destructive
now it's like you know we all want to be
like Florida all of a sudden and nothing
has changed of course many many many
things have changed when you look at
case numbers when you look at immunity
it's not even worth it okay the the
takeaway here is
DeSantis bullying children
into taking off their masks vile but
everything he said at this event reminds
me of how Trump was really really bad
if this guy is actually the nominee and
potentially becomes the next president
of the United States it will be worse
than with Trump this guy is just as
wacky but he's more competent and more
able to do all of the horrible things
that he would try to do let's hope it
does I'm not saying I'd rather Trump be
president it's a crazy thing to say but
in some way it might be less bad if
Trump were president Trump at nearly 80.
more incompetent and even presumably
lower energy just as a result of his age
seems less dangerous than Ron DeSantis
as president of the United States it's
my view as of today if you agree
disagree either way let me know what you
think Trump or DeSantis if you knew one
of them would be the next president let
me know on Twitter where you can find me
at dpacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show is after all a
viewer supported program a listener
supported program and I would encourage
you to get a membership at
joinpakman.com it's cheap it's quick
it's easy you'll get access to the world
famous bonus show every day you'll also
get a commercial free audio and video
feed of the show every day six hours
before everybody else why wait get the
show early by signing up at
joinpakman.com let's hear from people
people like you in the audience we do
calls via Discord davidpackman.com
Discord is the place to get in touch
with me let's go first today to Vince
from no Vince is gone that's too bad
let's go to Jason from Toronto Jason
you're on the air
Dave can you hear me I can hear you fine
it's a pleasure I've been watching your
show for a while I know and I want to
say that uh thanks for taking my call
and thanks for work on your end what you
do is invaluable so I really appreciate
that my pleasure uh quick question for
you
Trump we're still in power how do you
think you'd be handling the situation in
Ukraine
um do you think he'd just fooled his
hands over the situation and keep the us
out of the situation to kind of appease
his relationship with Russia or how do
you how do you think he would approach
it so I think in the this is a good
question in the lead up to the invasion
Trump would have placed heavy doubt on
the intelligence about Russia massing
troops at the border about Russia
imminently invading he would have
resisted that significantly early on and
he would have um so distrust about the
intelligence that pointed in that
direction and he would have said stuff
like you know why would Putin do this I
don't know I don't think so Putin denied
it very strongly or whatever that would
be in the lead-up once the invasion
takes place
um I think Trump would have similarly
early talked about genius Savvy Putin
just like he did but then as everybody
around him starts to say uh We've we've
got to help Ukraine here this is this is
a war of aggression being waged by Putin
Putin's clearly the aggressor we've got
to do something I think Trump would have
reluctantly been kind of pulled into
helping Ukraine in some way and it would
have been similar to when Trump on the
day of the riots put out that statement
saying it's time to go home you know
he's like we love you you're here for
the right reasons but it's time to go
home it would have been a similar sort
of like reluctant help of Ukraine that
that's the way I imagine it would have
gone yeah and I I'd appreciate that as
well I think
um NATO and and the Western uh resolve
against this or their position this
would be greatly diminished had Trump
still continue to hold the office there
so true I'm kind of glad that uh we have
somebody with a little bit more of a
level head uh taking care of it
um because I think it would be much
different uh had he still been around
100 thanks a lot for taking my call I
appreciate it thank you so much
appreciate it all right very good to
hear from you let's go next to Spencer
from California Spencer euron
hey David uh thanks for taking my calls
so to give a bit of background I'm
currently a student and one topic that
I'm not knowledgeable in is financial
literacy okay and partly just because it
was never taught in school and I haven't
learned from my parents either so my
question is twofold first what are some
resources for people in a similar
situation to get up to speed and second
do you think this is something that
should be taught in schools and starting
what
I think that Financial literally
literacy should absolutely be taught in
school probably starting in third or
fourth grade I think there's ways to to
start teaching these things in ways that
will be uh relevant to um kids at you
know eight nine ten years old about
budgeting and spending you can do things
in the classroom where you know you put
little bits of money aside and we say
these are going to be saved so that
later we as a class can do something and
you you kind of start that I think third
fourth fifth grade is a great time to do
that in terms of resources honestly here
here's the thing about it
there's a huge industry that is
predicated on convincing people that
personal finance is really complicated
now I don't want to say it's super easy
for everybody it's easy if you've been
given the right foundation but you don't
need some endless you know supply of
resources what what I recommend is
understand just like some basic there's
the basic principles of saving an
emergency fund these these types of
things bloggers like Mr Money Mustache
Nick majuli writers like Morgan housel
and others there's I'll put I should
really put together a resources list
with maybe like eight books and a few
websites for that will give you 98 of
what you need to know it doesn't have to
be complicated and there's a lot of
money spent by people who are convinced
that it is
um but stay away from stuff like you
know Christian ideologue Dave Ramsey who
purports to to give Financial advice and
he does and some of the advice is fine
but like he's an ideological right-wing
Christian anti-vaxx all this different
stuff you don't you don't need to get
your advice from people like that
right so so taxes would be something
similar where you think it's
learnable on your own sorry did you say
taxes
uh yeah yeah to do your own taxes
yeah I I noticed that like the tax
industry is
um a large one which is kind of
predicated on the fact that or they're
trying to make you believe that like you
need other people to help you right well
unfortunately I mean most people really
don't need others to do their taxes most
people's tax returns are very simple but
the thing about the tax code is the
companies that make the software want to
keep the tax code complicated and it
actually is complicated in many ways so
that one's a little bit different than
basic financial literacy
okay gotcha
all right thank you so much for the call
I appreciate it yeah good to be on all
right take care
let's see where do we want to go next a
lot of people want to chat today
um how about Ellie from Seattle Ellie
you're on the air
David how's it going it's going well
thank you
can you hear me okay yes I can
um a big fan of the show I've only been
watching
um for maybe about two months or so
um and you know I just wanted to say you
know in contrast to all of the negative
voicemails and emails that you get
um you just want to say I think you're
doing a great job I feel like like I
said I've only been watching for a
couple months I feel like I've learned a
lot from your show
um and just wanted to say thanks for all
the work you do um you do have a
question sure
um but you know it also uh you know
you've kind of inspired me to start
um making my own uh political videos so
um just thought you might like to know
that fantastic I I'm flattered
um so I have a divisive question
um might be more
than the facial hair question
so uh I'm originally from New York
um and I know that you know you hail
from you know Massachusetts and I think
I remember you saying on the one bonus
show that you're a Patriots fan
um so I have to ask about baseball okay
are are you a Red Sox fan yeah I'm a
casual Red Sox fan I I'm baseball is not
my big sport it's never been
oh okay I mean because like I said I
grew up in New York and you know I only
had the two options so of course I'm a
Yankees fan so
probably about as casual as you
um
that was that was really my only
question okay well yeah I I have I
unfortunately my answer is not super
exciting Ellie
all right you two uh there's Ellie from
Seattle with a sports question some
people like sports some people don't
let's go next to y'all from Ontario
Canada y'all you were on the air
hey can you hear me I can hear you fine
great I've never had a chance to be on
the show it was great um I wanted to ask
a couple questions
um first with the Democratic party just
for the State of the Union Address the
other day
um I saw the polls after the
after the address and it showed that
most Democrats weren't really favorable
because uh Biden's address mostly focus
on foreign policy and not
um inflation or the economy why are the
Democrats so poor at addressing issues
that are very important to the American
people
and should they be looking to push
people like Joe manchin out of the party
because it seems like they're afraid to
offend people
and instead of standing strong for
certain topics like before first of all
I I don't know that I agree with the
premise from from what I'm seeing a CBS
News poll found that
um 78 of Americans approved of the
speech either somewhat or strongly so I
guess the first thing is I don't know
that we're working with the same
information I didn't see this negative
response this was the polls right on CNN
right after the State of the Union oh
are you saying like on the website of
CNN
um this was I was watching CNN
um do an analysis right after the State
of the Union Address yeah and I just
went and you just you know just went to
show that I believe
um 68 show they were favorable towards
Joe Biden's um speech on foreign policy
toward the Ukraine address yeah and it
showed that 48 were satisfied with his
questioning on um on his address toward
uh the economy and inflation oh okay so
that was like like a topic by topic well
listen I don't know I didn't see that
data and a lot of times in the aftermath
of these speeches these are like very
informal like it's just who the people
that vote on our website it usually it
takes a while to get something a little
more formal
um I mean I think the so I'm not sure
about that I think that um in terms of
uh you're saying how why why aren't
Democrats good at addressing issues in a
way that people that resonates with
people is that generally what you're
asking yeah because it just seems like
you have such a wide fact based uh
factions in the Democratic party it just
seems like someone like Joe manchin as
an example doesn't seem like he wants to
play ball with the Democrats are trying
to do yeah any meaningful policy pass so
instead of trying to appeal appeal to
him why don't they just try to either
primary him or
um
trying to wait to like have a Democratic
Party stand for something that's solid
it doesn't seem like people really
believe the Democratic party stands for
anything or stands by an ending strongly
like the Republican Party does
yeah I I I don't know that I exactly
understand the question you're asking
but I mean I think on Joe manchin as
I've said before if you successfully
primary Joe manchin that almost
certainly gets flipped and it becomes a
republican seat I believe the solution
is you've got to flip Republican seats
you've got to flip Republican seats so
that Joe manchin doesn't have as much
power and the viability of doing that
this November in the what are going to
be probably tough midterms for Democrats
is a real question mark but in terms of
the messaging piece and what the
Republican party uh says the Democratic
Democratic party stands for versus what
the Democratic party actually says that
it stands for I have so many different
clips about this and part of this is
messaging part of this is not wanting to
turn people off you don't want to you
don't want to offend any slice of your
party which is impossible if you have
anything beyond an extremely narrow
Coalition so this is a long issue for
Democrats and I've spoken extensively
about it but I don't think the solution
to all of this as you primary Mansion I
think that that one could backfire and
two is is it it's too narrow a solution
okay and can I have one more question
Russia Ukraine sure um how much do you
think this is actually a failure of
American foreign policy like long term
are you saying how much is how much is
American foreign policy a cause of
what's Happening
oh yeah that's what I meant yes
um long term I think that it is uh I
mean the reason this is so tough is
in a globalized
Dynamic and complex world
we can't make a statement like nothing
the U.S has ever done is related to
Putin invading Ukraine like you that
would be that that would be wrong
obviously Ukraine and Russia exist on a
planet where the U.S has significant
influence but I think we have to be
really careful when we talk about blame
Putin decided to do this this was
optional and it is not the fault of
American foreign policy that Putin
decided to invade Ukraine and we've got
to be really really clear about that
yeah the reasoning why I think of it is
like with U.S foreign policy it seems a
bit hypocritical in the sense that
um as an example what separates people
are here bashing Vladimir Putin for
being a war criminal and I agree
but what separates him from George W
bush and then on top of that what
separates
as an example of what happened with the
Cuban Missile Crisis where there was
hostile weapons put into a neighboring
country and the US is ready to invade
them so isn't there like a massive
amount of hypocrisy in the U.S
foreigns are different they're not
exactly the same but the main point
you're making is there is always
hypocrisy on foreign policy from
countries that have the types of
militaries that do things around the
world the way the the American Military
does there's always some hypocrisy 100
percent
okay that was everything I had to ask
thank you all right thank you so much I
appreciate the phone call let's go next
to Joseph from Oregon Joseph you're on
the air
hi David uh thanks for taking my call I
appreciated your I appreciated your
coverage of the State of the Union last
night and uh or the other night
um
and I just wanted to ask a question kind
of about what
um kind of the strategy for Dems and
what they do going forward okay it
sounded like the speech was
vague and understandably optimistic but
overall it sounded like it was aimed at
d-leaning conservatives and centrists
and maybe without like the four things
Biden mentioned with like the opioid
crisis beating uh having better mental
health supporting our veterans and
ending cancer it didn't really sound
like there was an actual plan for those
things and maybe other than the opioid
crisis I'm not sure
if any of those items on the agenda are
really that popular so with the midterms
coming up like what do you think the
strategy should be for the Dems to get a
strong swing back in time for them in
terms I I actually think that it's less
about strategy but it's about you got to
get something done and I completely
agree with you and one of my critiques
after the State of the Union was I think
Joe Biden's rhetoric on the foreign
policy piece particularly Russia Ukraine
was strong uh I think it it ended strong
there were some good moments in the
middle but um the the sort of like
listing what was probably like a dozen
different things I mean he talked about
the four things you mentioned he talked
about controlling prices for Industries
charging too much talked about doing the
taxes where the rich in corporations
will pay more there was all this this
list of stuff almost all of which has no
path to happening certainly in the next
year if at all under Joe Biden's
presidency sadly I wish it were
different and
um I the the one place I disagree with
you is I think the whole point of those
four things Biden mentioned was that
while they might not be the issues the
audience is most passionate about
there's sort of like uncontroversial
like who doesn't want to end cancer
although some Republicans didn't even
clap for that which is crazy but I think
it was deliberate to create some moments
where everybody appears to be on the
same page so rhetorically I understand
it although I agree with you that it's
like those aren't the top issues for
most people I get that so I think it was
okay like I said I gave it a b
yeah sorry and I realized I I meant to
say too like of course like beating like
everyone wants to end cancer like that's
a popular thing I just don't think like
it legislate your way through cancer no
probably not I'm probably not that's
fair so that's fair
thank you for taking my call my pleasure
great to hear from you let's take a very
quick break we're not done with phone
calls so if you still want to talk to me
don't hang up Brokers are going to go
right back to the phones in a moment
if you value what we do at the David
Pacman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show we are
taking calls from you without you I'm a
guy in a room with a mic talking to the
wall and it's sad it's very sad but with
you guys here this is actually a show we
take calls via Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord and it is a it's a great thing
it's really a great thing let's go next
where are we going next let's go to
Houston and speak to Jorge Jorge you're
on the air
hi David uh I'm originally from Mexico
but I've lived uh here in Houston my
whole life okay and we have a very
trump-like president right now in Mexico
very narcissistic uh authoritarian uh
his last sort of uh hint that he was
going towards this very authoritarian
style was uh he hinted that he liked
Putin and he wasn't going to do any
sanctions so all this all this is uh was
sort of he sort of came to popularity
around Trump also what do you think it
is uh that people are so attracted to
these
narcissistic clown authoritarian types
so I don't know that much about uh the
authoritarian piece I mean I I know
about the sort of uh narcissism
and I but but it is at least ostensibly
a left-leaning Coalition in Mexico right
now I mean I guess what you're telling
me is that in practice it's
authoritarian
yeah so he he's sort of taken over the
military and they're doing uh
sort of his policing uh he's trying to
strengthen the military to to to sort of
solidify his power another play he
wanted was amend the Constitution so he
could stay in power for another term
thankfully uh he didn't win the Congress
so he can't really do that yeah but it's
those sort of things and so you're
wondering what it is about these
authoritarians that is appealing to
people
yeah yeah I think it's it's it's sort of
basic uh crowd psychology to some degree
and the idea that some some idea some
ideologies are easier to sell than
others and so like for example populism
populism is not a set of policies as as
I've talked about before populism is
really a rhetoric and that so when we
say left-wing populism or right-wing
populism we're not really talking about
policy some people will say there's no
such thing as right-wing populism right
well it's just it's rhetoric it's
populist rhetoric from right Wingers or
left Wingers and populist rhetoric is
very appealing to a lot of people the
devil is in what policies do you follow
it up with you see populist rhetoric
from the left and it's like Bernie
policies and then you see populist
rhetoric from the right and it's like
yeah and the problem the reason for all
our problems is you know brown people
from Mexico and so we've got to just
stop them from coming in so I think that
the Trump types Putin types Etc there's
a large population base that loves the
strong man of sorts and it's just
appealing no matter what policy is
behind it and that that's why it works
so often
yeah that makes sense it just I found it
very weird how Trump's policies are very
different from sort of these liberal
policies coming from Mexico yes they're
they're the same type of person you know
the narcissists are wanting to take
control manipulating people lying all
the time and it just seemed people were
really attracted to that 100 and
unfortunately sometimes it can work for
a long time it does it doesn't obviously
fail uh and um I mean listen we're
seeing we're seeing it around the world
it's not there's many places around the
world where we're seeing exactly that
and it's horrifying
yeah very scary thank you David all
right thank you for the call very much
appreciate it let's go next to Dave from
Brooklyn Dave you're on the air
hello can you hear me yes I can
um I have a long time listener this is
my second time Paul but I'm just calling
because um I wanted to get a little more
perspective on you from you because
you've been talking a lot recently about
the issues that we're facing as a left
and after listening to the the State of
the Union Address last night I feel like
it was so all over the place with so
little focus it just kind of reinforced
the message that you've been saying for
a while that as the
I left the progressor we have no focus
and I was wondering what if you were in
charge what are like the two three maybe
four things you would focus in on and
get done to start bringing people back
into our our full politically yeah
that's a good question listen is there a
TV in the background because it's very
tough to hear you over it
uh no worries I can disconnect and just
uh he listen to the answer oh okay all
right so yeah so listen if I I think
that um yes one of the one of my
critiques of the State of the Union was
that it really was all over the place
with like no transitions whatsoever Joe
Biden was going from uh we're gonna
control prices when businesses are
charging too much without saying why to
we're going to change taxes and we're
stopping flights from Russia and we're
going to beat cancer and you know all
these it was it was very much all over
the place which is okay it's okay for a
state of the union to lay out a big
Vision that includes a lot of different
things I if it were me right now saying
the left has to be focused I would try
to narrow things a little bit and say
okay we've got to pick one or two things
on the economic Justice front so there's
all these different things there's
minimum wage totally changing the tax
code uh undoing tax loopholes student
loan debt all these different things I
would I would say like let's pick two
specific things on the economic side
that we're going to do let's come up
with a pro-business plan on the
environment and really just lay out
again one or two things here's the
lowest hanging fruit on how we can both
support business
and help the environment and whether
it's a green energy Focus or whatever
find like two things there and then
thirdly make some kind of clear
statement
um to some degree I I hope about the
state of democracy and simplify what
really needs to be done to take the
narrative back that from the those who
on the right who are now saying
elections just can't be trusted and
anybody could have really won you'd have
no way of knowing that's very dangerous
and demoralizing it also happens to be
untrue so I think that's what I would do
I would say number one let's get just a
simple message out there to undo all of
this stuff that's been opened up about
the big lie and Trump really won and all
that we got to put a stop to that and
get people really thinking uh clearly
about what's actually going on number
two let's do something that feels good
about the environment but that also is
very clearly not going to be bat quote
bad for business the way many on the
right say anything we do to deal with
climate change it's going to be terrible
for business no it doesn't have to be
that way and then again on something
economic just pick say we're going to
make these three changes to the tax code
and we'll pay 10 grand of student debt
that's it and then you you have to
restrict the conversation and this will
upset that some people some people say
no but you're not including minimum wage
in that or you didn't include this I I
get it you can't ever do anything so why
even pretend like you can let's really
narrow the message and say Here's what
we're what we're going to get done that
would be my suggestion
let's go next to Aiden in Cleveland
Aiden you're on the air
hello can you hear me yes I can
so
at the moment I'm kind of just very
confused about the situation in Ukraine
okay like many others I've seen on
different news sources how there's the
Convoy heading to key bombings
throughout the country yep and just in
knowing all of that I'm kind of confused
as to why there hasn't been any military
intervention from NATO or anyone else
and I'm not saying that I support that I
understand I also don't believe that we
should just let Russia take over the
country and do as they please I totally
understand what you're saying um my
understanding and things are changing so
quickly that by the time this clip is
published things may have changed my
understanding is
that there is still this idea of keeping
some gas in the tank so to speak keeping
more things that you can do
if Putin escalates further now you're
bringing up a good question which is
like what is there what escalation is
there Beyond literally trying to take
the capital of Ukraine right it's it's a
it's a totally fair question I don't
know I don't know the exact calculus but
I think the principle that's at play is
leaving things that you can still do and
it's not clear to me I mean listen you
Ukraine is not a NATO country so I think
that NATO to send troops probably needs
to be able to more directly justify that
at this point the invasion is actually
encroaching on NATO country borders that
may be something that is a milestone
that they're waiting for but we don't
really know the answer we're just kind
of thinking out loud
okay thank you I just wanted your input
in that yeah that's my best assessment
right now and we don't have full
information
thank you yeah my pleasure thank you so
much we're taking calls via Discord
davidpackman.com Discord is the place to
go and the way that you can talk to me
let's go next to angel from New York
angel you're on the air
angel from New York welcome you're on
the air
oh sorry about that I was muted
now you're unmuted
oh we're good all right uh my question
for you I mean I work for a public
sector Trade union a fairly powerful one
is that uh my question to you is uh why
do so many people in these trade unions
um
not talking about teachers or police
since it's fair wide fairly obvious
where they fall politically and why they
do but why do other people firefighters
uh Steel Workers why do they seem to
lean to the right not just on cultural
issues but even economic ones and what
can the left do about that because it
seems like an unwinnable battle so I
take issue with one aspect of what
you're saying I think you are 100
correct that a lot of the kind of
laborer Trade union members have
absolutely moved to the right in terms
of how they vote over the last 20 years
and uh I think that the part where
you're wrong is if you really sit down
and talk to these folks about economic
issues they're they're very clearly on
the left the problem is that the
cultural conservatism of some of those
unions combined with people who just are
busy living their lives and aren't
really thinking through the economic
issues and the proposals of candidates
are just kind of saying yeah I I believe
I'm a republican but when you really
talk to them about economic issues the
things they tell you line up with what
Democrats are mostly proposing and not
with Republicans so it's unfortunate
because they're still voting for
Republicans but I don't actually think
that they have moved to the right
economically I think they just think
they have and they're part of these
culturally conservative environments and
so they just go I'm a republican I'm
voting for Republicans but if you really
sat them down you'd see that they really
align with Democrats on economic issues
yeah I suppose you're right I uh it's
more of a signaling thing like I you
know I've got family members I know
friends these people
they'll work for a public sector Trade
union which even we have reservations
about collective bargaining against the
taxpayer but uh you know like one guy
will have a like the Gadsden flag Don't
Tread on Me yep uh at the very least
they'll signal they'll they'll signal
issues with high taxes or or gas prices
so I do think that if if you sat them
down and really tried to get at how they
feel about things they're definitely to
the left
and then uh I guess where I'm seeing it
economically is still it still could be
grouped under under a cultural
understanding of where they land yeah I
mean with a lot of these folks if you
say what do you see is wrong with the
economy how would you fix it you're
going to get a discourse that points to
Democrats not to Republicans the problem
is they still Mo there's a lot of them
still vote for republicans and that's
sad but when you really talk to them you
would see that they Point left
yeah so what do uh what do Democrats do
about that I don't know that I mean it's
again it's a messaging failure I don't
know the answer if if I knew the answer
I'd be a political political consultant
but I don't know it's just an area
Democrats continue to fail on
um all right well thanks for talking to
me all right appreciate the call yeah I
wish I had something a little more I
guess optimistic to say
um that's gonna do it uh that's gonna
thank you so much Angel from uh from New
York appreciate it that's gonna do it
for calls today I as always was unable
to get to every caller but I'm going to
try to get to more callers when we take
calls again we'll take a quick break and
be right back with more show
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right everybody it's mailbag time it
is uh that time of the week where I look
through the mailbag we are now getting
man what are we up to we get about a
thousand emails a week now I would say
uh like actual emails you know some
people say uh total number of comments
we're we get like four to five thousand
comments a day if you include tweets
Facebook comments Instagram comments
Instagram messages YouTube comments
email everything together email someone
actually taking time to email info
davidpackman.com it's about a thousand a
week and I want to highlight some
different things for you here today all
relevant in some way as a reminder if
you are new to this program new to our
environment
um one of the things that I've just
accepted as part of doing this as as my
my thing is uh really horrible people
write to me and Bill for example wrote
to me and said show my email on your
YouTube page you effing Jew F and then
that second f is the you know the
pejorative for a gay person
um this is every day so every day of the
five thousand
100 to 150 are this type of thing this
is the world we live in we can't just
say hey you know what David I disagree
with you about how taxes should be
organized no it's you effing Jew f
IST this does not bode well for society
this is not making me think we're very
close to achieving some greater level of
understanding and problem solving by
working to get no it doesn't seem that
that's the the way it's going to go next
email who pays you
I sort of love this question in a way
because you know sometimes this question
is overtly anti-semitic like what take
your Soros Jew money and stop pushing
communism you know whatever
um but it's actually I I love the way
that we're organized which is our number
one funding source is people in our
audience it's just people people who ask
the question it's people like you not
you but people like you that pay us
through our membership program and yeah
you know we're part of YouTube's
monetization program Facebook's when
they allow us we've got some advertisers
Etc
but basically we're viewer funded and
um that's a great thing because there's
no one person that can say David unless
you do or say x we're gonna pull your
funding if one member comes to me as
they sometimes do uh and recently did
which we'll get to in a moment and says
David unless you take Exposition I'm
pulling my funding well pull your two
bucks a month pull your sixty dollars a
year or whatever
um nobody has us under their thumb
because so many different people fund us
so that's who pays us and it's a really
really great thing okay a lot of
controversy surprisingly I guess over
the pronunciation of the capital of
Ukraine one such person wrote to me and
said David it's pronounced Kiev
and then a couple hours later they wrote
back and full respect to them they said
my apologies I just checked it you're
right the back story on this and the
reason why we now say Kiev and spell it
k-y-i-v
is that much like in what's a good
example this isn't a perfect example but
you guys know how the name Weinberg in
English sometimes you see it spelled
w-e-i and sometimes it's w-i-e sometimes
it's w-a-i and at the end the Berg part
sometimes it's b-e-r-g sometimes it's
b-u-r why why is that well it's being
it's it's it's being translated
um from languages Hebrew Yiddish which
don't always put the vowels in so it
really it's the root it's the the W and
wnbrg and the vowels sort of don't
matter so there's different ways you can
do it and similarly when it comes to
Kiev
for a while it was a more anglicized
spelling k-i-e-v and when people looked
at k-i-e-v logically they said that's
Kiev
it was eventually updated and NPR and
other media Outlets announced when they
were doing this they said you know
really the the more proper spelling
would be k-y-i-v
in translating from the Cyrillic and uh
as a result we're also going to be
calling it Kiev which is more in line
with the actual Ukrainian pronunciation
so this is actually this this is a
Year's old story because of what's going
on in Russia Ukraine now more people are
talking about it and gladly so all right
I told you there are people
pulling financial support and looking to
hurt us very badly and a lot of those
people like Tulsi gabbard we actually do
have a fraction of our audience that
likes Tulsi and they don't like that
last week I said
Tulsi is a confirmed scammer grift or
whatever and so one such person is
Robert Robert wrote to me and said dear
David at least he's polite dear David I
have unsubscribed from your show because
you Reveal Your our tribal your our
tribal you look for labels and you
follow the liberal official narrative
Tulsi gabbard speaks to citizens of all
labels calling us to remember our common
ground is far greater than our pet
peeves be well wake up Robert Robert has
canceled his membership that's right
Robert pulled his six bucks a month and
so what I'm asking you is if you don't
like this kind of stuff I would love for
you to sign up on our website
joinpakman.com I think there's many more
people in our audience who support what
we do
and understand the Tulsi scam then the
people like Robert who are trying to
hurt us financially for making that
assessment Vincent wrote in Vincent said
dear David thank you for speaking the
truth about Tulsi gabbard she's been
spreading lies and Russian propaganda
since the beginning and it's important
to counter those lies keep doing what
you're doing best Vincent thank you
Vincent and I will tell you the vast
majority of the feedback to us saying
guys if you fell for the Tulsi scam it's
over
just say you were wrong and say you're
going to do better next time you you now
have learned it was a mistake but you
learned and now you won't fall for
similar scams in the future
overwhelmingly people reacting very
positively to that very positively
people uh uh saying things like what
Vincent says every once in a while
though someone like Robert canceling his
membership comes through
next email is from Cindy Cindy has an
idea about how to refer to Trump she
says I have an idea I would love to see
it catch on maybe if you would it would
if you would use it every time Donald
Trump refers to someone who opposes him
or an organization that opposes him he
loves to use the word failed in front of
their name or title like the failed New
York Times
failed gubernatorial candidate whoever
What If instead of referring to him as
former president Donald Trump we started
referring to him as failed presidential
candidate Donald Trump truthful accurate
and utterly triggering love what you do
keep it up yeah I think um I like this
idea I'm going to make an effort and
sometimes it's really hard to kind of
use the the Lexicon that one uh tends to
use I'm going to make an effort to say
instead of former president Donald Trump
I'm going to say failed president Donald
Trump because he did fail and he failed
by his own standards it's not just my
assessment from the left that he failed
the things he said he would do he never
did he said he would build a wall across
the entire U.S Mexico border he didn't
do it he said he would fix trade he
didn't do it he said he would put out a
beautiful replacement plan for ObamaCare
that would be great for everybody not
only did he not get that done he didn't
even tell us what the plan is or how it
will work remember in August of 2019 it
was two weeks away I think from coming
out it never did uh by his own standards
by his own standards he he is a failed
president so Cindy I like the way you're
thinking I'm going to try to refer to
Trump as failed president Donald Trump
a bunch of people writing to me about my
rant about electric vehicles last week
someone emailed or left a voicemail
rather and said David
most electricity still comes from fossil
fuels so our electric cars really better
I laid out a ton of reasons why they are
but I missed some reasons and Rickard
wrote in and said David just listen to
you explaining why electric cars are
better are the better environmental
Choice compared to gas powered
everything you said is valid I want to
add another argument which will make it
much more tangible I used to own a Volvo
v40 because I'm Swedish makes sense it's
a small hatchback comparable to a small
sedan it consumed roughly half a liter
of diesel per 10 kilometers which
translates to five kilowatt hours I now
own a Tesla Model 3 and it consumes 1.6
to 2.3 kilowatt hours per 10 kilometers
in other words the Tesla is much more
energy efficient this means even if all
the electricity produced from powering
electric cars was produced by burning
diesel it's still more efficient to use
electric cars and I totally missed this
and this is a really good point we can
say well you go a hundred miles
with gap burning gas or you go 100 miles
using electricity derived from burning
coal either way it's fossil fuels but
the point here is the efficiency of
doing it through electricity is
significantly higher even accounting for
the heavier Vehicles because the
batteries are heavy that's a really
really good point from Rickard and then
one more here similar idea for Mark
Mark wrote in and said David love the
segment about switching to electric and
Renewables but you miss the big Point
even if one hundred percent of
electricity was generated by burning
fossil fuels the power plants are more
than four times as energy efficient
versus the gas powered engine in your
car keep up the good work so a similar
idea which is if you have all of the
burning of gas happening in a hundred
thousand cars that has one level of
efficiency in converting that fossil
fuel to movement in the vehicle
if it's done centrally at a power plant
and then distribute it out via
electricity it is more efficient in
terms of how much fossil fuel
consumption there is for moving those
hundred thousand cars some distance 10
miles 100 miles whatever the case may be
so I understated I understated the
relative efficiencies of electric
vehicles
um in the segment last week but so many
people in our in our audience very keyed
into that and loved the opportunity to
say more about it if you have an email
you can email info davidpackman.com it
may be selected remember we get about a
thousand a week we feature ten so those
are those are the odds uh make of it
what you will and we have a fantastic
bonus show coming up for you today sign
up at joinpackman.com we will see you
then